bobby it seemed like a very heavy
theoretical game did you ever feel that
you suddenly got in the back foot
i don't know i think it was always a
draw i mean
after king d3
yeah i guess i can play c5 or something
i mean there's i think pretty much every
move is objectively a draw here
uh and king d3 should be one of them but
then he made it interesting he played
this rook d4
did you know that this move rook did had
to be met with king c2 or did you just
start thinking during the game no i i
didn't know
um i mean i was thinking for quite a
while at probably like at least 20
minutes i'm not sure exactly and yeah
kingiforwiki and i just couldn't figure
out if this bishop ending is a draw uh
let me let's go one second king four
rookie eight ah this one that you were
mentioning king d3 rookie sex right yeah
i wasn't sure if this is a draw i had a
feeling it probably is but i thought
here it it will be rather difficult to
foresee everything and king c2
um rook d4 i
i thought i should have more than one
way to draw more than one way to draw
after this it felt to me like this is a
very drawish position
uh yeah a5 h4 um like in this position i
just thought there should be multiple
moves that would make a draw here but
rook a6 is the most straightforward one
yes okay six and
levon showed us quite a few
lines in this position yeah rook g4 is
is probably dubious for the
i see the variation that he gave on the
screen yeah um it might also be a drop
after a6 at least he has to prove the
draw right uh and
and so what he did is normal i mean
after king b3 again he has many moves
which should be a draw like i feel like
rook g4 rook c6 is a draw yes correct
that one rope g2 a6 and like rook g3 or
i mean i think maybe bishop one bishop
c5 gets dangerous maybe yes maybe that's
bad but i thought rook g3 would be a
draw at some moment like a rock g3
immediately at some moment he throws his
check in and we probably go back and
forth like i have let's say king b2 here
for example um
yeah he can go back or because if bishop
you won bishop c5 then he doesn't have
access to the a file that's why i keep
my key on the b file right uh
anyway some lines like this felt very
dryish and
uh rook c1 bishop c3 can have i started
to feel like maybe there's some like
tiny tribe but i couldn't see it at all
like first of all rook c6 bishop v5 it
rook c6 here bishop b5 is important
uh and i guess it's also a draw but then
i felt like i have to prove it because
of king b2 he has this tricky move
rookie one
and oh
and
we get some rook ending where i think
that i'm the one who has to prove a draw
right even if you get the rook somehow
at the end there's a lot of pawns coming
yeah it'll take me a long time to get
the rook so
um rook a7 was just like um
just a way to clean up the game because
i have like rook b6 i have rook 8 but
rook 8 i thought was a try and then i
saw this f6 move and again he kind of
trades
trades the bishops and i thought okay
why go through this suddenly he's the
one who has a did you should be five you
mean yeah a6 bishop b5
um
take take i mean again should be a draw
but why but but yeah but why why would i
do this when rook a7
is a completely clinical force draw
you've debated this particular
line quite often do you feel like it's
running out of steam or do you feel
there's still stuff to look at here
i think it might be running out of steam
i mean i played this against level one
in 2018 twice exactly this long castle
thing well we the first time i um
i think i'm we both messed something up
in the opening and we got something else
entirely but this specific end game
after long castle i played in a rapid
um
tie break against him which was very
important we were playing a match and
and based on that game i won the match
and i think like i once played a match
against grishouk where i must have
played this exact line like five times
and uh so yeah one of the showdowns here
in saint louis yeah in 2017. so
i think i'm probably the player who's
played this c3d5 ed5 the most like i
have
easily a dozen games in this position
after 85 queen e5 bishops before queen
d6 so
uh
i might have to look for different
directions you've played levon over 150
times considering rapid blitz and
classical and that's just over the board
do you feel it ever gets difficult to
prepare against such a player
um
not so much but i did realize that some
of the
openings that he plays we have discussed
and so i had to think about that before
the game
uh like
he he at some point had a phase where he
was playing the
b5 bishop c5 spanish archangel
very frequently and we started checking
it so i had to think about what i would
play that we hadn't specifically looked
at
uh and
okay this line we've never really
checked because it's such a deadline
there's no point checking it i was
hoping that he
because it's kind of forgotten by now
it's like this was resolved years ago
that i i i was hoping he had maybe
forgotten some details about this line
and then it's very tricky but he
remembered it extremely extremely well
yeah certainly he hasn't forgotten any
of these details perhaps that loss
really
uh put him in his memory well thank you
for joining us here i think we'll have a
couple more interviews let me just
update really quickly what's going on
between dominguez and alireza no draw it
seems like uh lures is the one declining
a draw with the move queen c5 so we'll
still explain for a win here uh well
that would how do we play for one after
queen like it well because you didn't
play king d7 on claim a draw because it
will be a three-pole repetition like
queen c5 queen e4 between d5 queen c2
king is this really his attempt yeah md7
queen seven king d8 that's
yeah i guess i mean if you're
and off we go if you're
19 and super ambitious then
then this is what you do yeah we
remember those days don't we
all right father thank you for joining
us here at the
thank you youth is wasted on the young